we're gonna move on now to Ukraine where
Russian troops have been driven out of
another major city a key one Ukrainian
forces have recaptured Lehman it's a
major crossroads in eastern Ukraine and
this happened just over the weekend
Russia is responding with more
long-range attacks and still more
civilians have been killed as a result
Charlie dagada is in Ukraine for us as
he has been for weeks Charlie good
morning
good morning T Tony this is the
aftermath of one of those long-range
attacks or to bus depot in dinipro it
was hit by a missile strike a few nights
ago more explosions here this morning
further attacks on civilian targets
while Russian forces lose ground on the
battlefields
Ukrainian paratroopers swept into Lehman
over the weekend after a hard-fought
battle flying the flag for the first
time in months recapturing the Strategic
City in the East marks one of the most
significant victories of the war and the
Ukrainian flag will soon fly in other
regions without a defiant Ukrainian
president saying the successes of our
soldiers are not limited to Lehmann
even as he spoke overnight his Ukrainian
soldiers were advancing in the country's
south unverified social media posts
suggest they pushed Russian troops back
around 25 miles in just one day
the rapid-fired territorial takeover
slices right into regions President
Putin claimed as his own on Friday in
his illegal annexation of four
territories in Ukraine in his mind
that's now Russian soil the mayor of
Russian occupied malitipole kidnapped in
the early days of the war then released
in a prisoner swap says he expects a
massive escalation what sort of
military statement do you think
President Putin may make now I think he
used he can use a nuclear weapons on
this territories to make his military
tasks
that has put cities like denipro on edge
where the Russian military is already
stepped up attacks on civilian Targets
in recent days
it's not exactly clear what the intended
target was but a massive Russian missile
completely destroyed this home in a
residential neighborhood neighbors tell
us a grandmother a mother and two small
children were killed as they slept
we watched as tearful residents paid
tribute laying flowers and toys young
lives taken in a random rocket attack
miles from the front line others
wandered in shock in disbelief and fear
of where and when the next Rockets will
strike
there are no obvious military targets at
this Depot either but it has crippled
the public transportation system while
we're learning Ukrainian forces have
taken even more ground south of here
this morning Nate
Charlotte and Ukraine thank you